la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas
le procès-verbal est donc adopté sous
les réserves d'usage
mes chers collègues
en votre nom
j'ai le plaisir de saluer la présence
dans la tribune d'honneur d'une
délégation du Sénat de la République de
Madagascar
la délégation est conduite par son
président composé de trois sénateurs
dont le doyen et le questeur de cette
assemblée elle est accompagnée par notre
collègue nassimadada président du groupe
d'amitié France Madagascar et les pays
de l'Océan Indien
la délégation
que j'ai reçu ce matin avec Roger
carochi avec xori et la présidente de la
délégation est en France jusqu'au 10
avril sa visite d'études s'inscrit dans
le cadre des relations
privilégiées et que nous souhaitons
renforcer entre nos deux pays
en fin de journée elle rencontrera les
membres de la délégation au
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation présidé par notre
collègue Françoise Gatel ainsi que nos
collègues qui composent le groupe
d'amitié France Madagascar et pays de
l'Océan Indien le Sénat français
entretient d'excellents rapports de
confiance et d'amitié avec le Sénat de
Madagascar et souhaite les renforcer
nous sommes
particulièrement attentifs au
renforcement de la coopération
décentralisée entre les collectivités
territoriales françaises et malgages
dans les perspective d'assise de la
décentralisation qui se tiendront à
Madagascar sans doute l'an prochain
et naturellement renforcement avec nos
territoires
ultramarins je pense à la Réunion et à
Mayotte tout particulièrement
permettez-moi mes chers collègues de
souhaiter en votre nom à tous à notre
homologue président du Sénat malgache et
à nos collègues sénateurs la plus
cordiale bienvenue ainsi qu'un excellent
et fructueux séjour dans notre pays
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns et des
autres et au respect du temps de parole
et je donne immédiatement la parole à
notre collègue Matthieu d'Arnaud pour le
gros plaid républicain
merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le président de la République a
dévoilé le temps attendu plan o la
semaine dernière dans les Hautes-Alpes
si nous pouvons souscrire à certaines
orientations que nous avions nous-mêmes
pointé du doigt dans le rapport de la
délégation à la prospective sur l'avenir
de l'eau il
certains points nous inquiète en
revanche s'agissant de la question des
financements
déjà ici au Sénat notre collègue Rémi
Cointreau avait à l'époque dans un
rapport dénoncé que l'eau ne payait plus
l'eau mais que l'eau payait l'État et de
constater malheureusement qu'après avoir
ponctionné près de 400 millions par an
sur le budget des agences de l'eau pour
financer l'Office français de la
biodiversité vous avez souhaité
restituer 475 millions d'euros aux
agences de l'eau
habile tour de passe-passe c'est
ingénieux créatif mais la ficelle et
pour nous un petit peu grosse et cela ne
nous permettra pas de résoudre les
problématiques selon nous impérieuse
pour notre pays s'agissant de la
question de l'eau nous avons toutefois
noté la volonté du Président de la
République de faire écho à la
proposition de loi que nous avons votée
ici au Sénat s'agissant de la
gouvernance différenciée de l'eau et de
la capacité à rendre facultative le
transfert aux intercommunalités alors ma
question est simple et directe écran de
fumée ou véritable volonté d'agir je
vous remercie
pour vos réponses
la parole est à Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur d'Arnaud d'abord je voudrais
vous remercier de vous être rendu
hommage à vous-même je l'avais fait par
anticipation en répondant à Guillaume
chevrolier juste avant le plan haut
disant que vous retrouveriez une partie
de vos petits puisque nous étions appuyé
sur le rapport récent de la Cour des
comptes sur le rapport de la mission
d'inspection après l'été mais également
sur des rapports parlementaires et en
particulier sur le rapport de la
délégation sénatoriale à la prospective
et donc il est logique et légitime que
vous saluez des propositions qui pour un
grand nombre d'entre elles ont été
reprises la question des moyens elle est
cruciale et centrale
nous nous sommes appuyés là aussi sur la
concertation avec les premiers concernés
les comités de bassins et les agences de
l'eau qui avaient deux attentes sur la
question des moyens vous avez peut-être
été un peu vite sur l'un des deux mais
l'annonce de la suppression des plafonds
mordants qui était attendu sur la
totalité des territoires et qui était
une contrainte sur les niveaux de
dépenses et de subvention qui pouvaient
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales étaient une demande
unanime des territoires qui est
satisfaite dans le cadre du Plan o
ensuite il y a la question des moyens
les prêts de 500 millions de supplément
de crédit pour les agences de l'eau que
vous évoquez ça correspondait à la fois
au chiffrage exprimé par le Conseil
national et par les comités de bassins
partout sur le territoire donc on n'est
pas dans l'incantation on est dans la
réponse à ces sujets et vous il faut
ajouter le milliard d'euros d'aqua-prés
rendu possible par la Caisse des dépôts
et consignations j'ai bien conscience
qui avait deux volets dans votre
question une concernant les financements
une concernant la gouvernance mais comme
une masse semblait voir que le sénateur
Arnaud posait une question juste après
vous sur la question de la gouvernance
je vais commencer à vous répondre dans
les 20 secondes qu'il me reste et je
finirai dans la question qui arrive
après pour vous dire que c'est tout sauf
un écran de fumée le président de la
République au cours de ces 53 mesures a
répondu d'une manière directe aux
interrogations que peuvent avoir un
certain nombre d'élus communaux et je
vais avoir l'occasion de vous préciser
le cadre dans lequel nous le faisons
dans quelques instants pour ne pas
dépasser le temps de parole qui met un
parti monsieur d'Arnaud
oui merci monsieur le ministre nous
serons très vigilants comptés sur la
vigilance du Sénat pour veiller à ce que
vos propos qui relaient sur du président
de la République se traduisent par des
actes mais aujourd'hui l'impériorité
c'est d'accompagner nos territoires et
au-delà des financements faire en sorte
que leur fléchage permettent à
l'ensemble des communes de faire face à
ce défi qui est celui de l'eau parce que
celui qui vous parle vient d'un
département ou 26 communes viennent de
se voir interdire de délivrer des permis
de construire et l'enjeu de l'eau il est
là aussi c'est le développement de nos
territoires merci
la parole
à notre collègue Jean-Michel Arnaud pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste oui merci
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre comme ça
a été dit par mon collègue d'Arnaud le
président de République est venu dans
mon département présenté le plan-haut la
semaine dernière les mesures présentées
dans ce plan on le mérite de fixer un
cap alors que la politique de l'autre
Tanguay depuis tant d'années le
président notamment appelé un
tarification progressive et
responsabilisante de l'eau souhaitant
qu'elle soit en concertation avec les
élus généralisée en France cela signifie
que les premiers mètres cubes seront
facturés un prix modeste proche du prix
coûtant puis au-delà d'un certain niveau
plus on consommera plus le prix sera
plus élevé cela paraît simple sur le
papier en pratique cela sera beaucoup
moins facile la mesure suppose que les
consommateurs soient informés de leur
consommation d'eau en temps réel pour se
faire ils vont être dotés de compteurs
intelligents or seulement 40% des foyers
possède un comment avez-vous prévu de
généraliser ces compteurs par ailleurs
se posera également le problème de la
tarification il devra prendre ce
problème en compte à la fois le volume
d'eau consommé mais aussi les usages qui
sont faits de cette eau allez vous
mettre en place une hiérarchie des
usages si oui comment certifiera-t-elle
avec la tarification progressive puisque
nous Vous invitez monsieur le ministre
je vous invite également à préciser la
gouvernance locale de l'eau puisque je
n'avais pas envisagé de poser la
question mais comme elle est sur toutes
les lèvres et éventuellement dans votre
conscience j'attends avec beaucoup
d'attention votre réponse
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Arnaud vous étiez au premier
horloge à savine-le-lac au moment de
cette présentation sur l'ensemble de ses
annonces
le Sénat s'est fait l'écho y compris au
travers d'un vote ici de l'inquiétude de
vouloir fixer une règle qui soit unique
en France et posant la question mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on refuse de
maintenir des systèmes de gestion
communaux quels sont les indicateurs et
les éléments qui permettent d'expliquer
pourquoi on voudrait faire une mars
forcée vers l'intercommunalité les
indicateurs ils existent et ils
expliquent le fait que le président a
commencé par rappeler que préserver un
système de gestion de l'eau avec des
communisolées n'étaient pas une option
80% des communes privées d'eau potable
l'année dernière gérer l'eau de manière
seule
sans cesse des 170 communes dans les
niveaux de fuite dépasse les 50% gerlo
de façon seule mais ce que le président
a dit ce que je reviens redire
aujourd'hui à l'ensemble du Sénat c'est
que l'enjeu c'est de sortir de la
communion isolée sans nécessairement
aller vers une
intercommunalité d'autres formes de
mutualisation pouvant prendre le relais
l'enjeu
l'enjeu et c'est le point d'équilibre
qui nous reste à trouver
pas de commune seule mutualisation mais
des formes qui tiennent compte de la
topographie de la géographie de la
réalité des territoires voilà Mesdames
et Messieurs le point d'équilibre sur
lequel nous pouvons aller sur lequel à
l'intérieur un bout de mission
parlementaire nous permettrait sans
doute de préciser la manière dont les
choses pourraient se faire sur la
tarification sociale voilà un chantier à
partir d'un principe simple il s'agit
pas de pénaliser les familles nombreuses
il s'agit de trouver un dispositif qui
fasse en sorte que pour des usages de
confort on soit capable d'objectiver les
situations et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons confier aux saisons
dans un premier temps une demande de
préconisation pour ensuite évoquer avec
vous avec les associations des liloko
qui ont la responsabilité de la
tarification vous serez évidemment
associé et entendu comme vous l'avez été
dans le cadre de ce plan lancé par la
première ministre conclu par le
Président de la République
Monsieur Arnaud
oui c'est le ministre le président de la
République a annoncé dans mon
département vouloir un modèle pluriel et
différencié
j'entends que vous nous annoncez
aujourd'hui je vous en remercie la
possibilité de créer à nouveau des
syndicats pour gérer la compétence haut
au plus près du territoire vous avez
également annoncé la création d'une
mission parlementaire nous y
collaborerons et je pense qu'il sera
nécessaire effectivement de préciser les
choses y compris dans des situations
particulières le maintien d'une
compétence communale là où c'est
nécessaire pas forcément partout parce
que nous cherchons un compromis et je
souhaite que nous puissions avancer
avant les prochaines semaines dans les
prochaines semaines pour que nous soyons
prêts avant le 1er janvier 2026 date
butoir du transfert de la compétence
dans tous les cas je salue votre
ouverture et nous travaillerons ensemble
pour trouver des solutions
la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Noëlle linman pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président chers collègues madame la
Première ministre
votre réunion avec l'Inter syndicale
s'est terminé par un échec
à vrai dire c'était prévisible tant
votre gouvernement est le président de
la République
sentait à ne pas vouloir entendre les
Français le Parlement et le monde du
travail
vous vous êtes engagé dans une stratégie
jusqu'au-boutiste qui amène au désordre
comme si vous imaginiez sortir de
l'impasse politique et du rejet massif
des reculs sociaux par la méthode du
rappel à l'ordre et de la peur du chaos
mais les Français ne sont pas dupe car
c'est une crise démocratique qui
s'ajoute à la crise sociale c'est très
grave pour notre pays son avenir est la
confiance du peuple en la République
alors madame la Première ministre il est
temps d'atterrir quand retirez-vous la
réforme des retraites
pour vous répondre la parole est ton
ministre du Travail du plein emploi de
l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du somme
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
ministrymann ce matin effectivement avec
la première ministre et son invitation
nous avons reçu l'interdicale toute
l'incertitude puisque l'ensemble des
organisations étaient présentées
une réunion importante nous avons pu
écouter chacun d'entre eux et l'échange
entre le gouvernement la première
ministre et les organisations syndicales
a été un échange respectueux nous avons
entendu le désaccord répété de leur part
sur le relèvement de l'âge de départ et
pour certains d'entre eux sur la
fermeture des régimes spéciaux nous
avons aussi évoqué un certain d'autres
sujets je pense aux carrières longues je
pense à la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle je pense à tout ce qui
fait finalement l'accompagnement des
carrières et un certain nombre de
mesures qui jalonnent à la fois la
carrière professionnelle et les
retraites le désaccord qui persiste
entre les organisations syndicales le
j'aimerais sa majorité sur la question
de l'âge n'a pas permis d'approfondir
plus avant les thèmes que je viens
d'évoquer nous avons entendu comme vous
madame la ministre que le représentant
de l'Inter syndical à la sortie de cette
réunion avait indiqué que les mêmes
organisations syndicales souhaité
pouvoir
ultérieurement travailler sur ces
sujets-là nous y sommes favorables et la
première ministre a eu l'occasion de
leur dire que nous sommes prêts
lorsqu'ils seront prêts lorsqu'il le
souhaiteront à ouvrir l'ensemble de ces
chantiers à l'occasion de cette réunion
nous avons pu aussi la première ministre
a pu plus singulièrement encore le
rappeler la conviction du gouvernement
cela nécessite de cette réforme
nécessitait face à un déficit n'hésitez
pas à un système qui n'agissons pas va
se dégrader si vous permettez cette
expression va aller dans le mur donc
nous souhaitons mener cette réforme
aujourd'hui le texte est au Conseil
constitutionnel nous attendons sa
décision pour ensuite pouvoir mettre en
œuvre cette réforme
madame
bon je veux bien qu'on fasse semblant de
croire que c'était important de son
temps pour entendre les syndicats mais
enfin je m'excuse fallait être sourd
mais archi sourd pour ne pas avoir
entendu leurs arguments par avant les
sujets que vous évoquez carrière longue
pénibilité c'est au cœur des débats que
nous avons eu ici et pour la réforme
alors Monsieur le Ministre puisque ce
serait une nécessité fondamentale pour
la France
si vous ne voulez pas revenir sur le
retrait organiser un référendum n'ayez
pas peur du peuple demander leur avis et
leur arbitrage c'est peut-être la seule
façon de sortir de cette entêtement qui
est le vôtre nous exigeons un référendum
ou le retrait
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
Dagbert pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur François
Braun ministre de la santé et de la
prévention monsieur le ministre ce lundi
3 avril est entré en vigueur la loi
riste et notamment son article 33
relatif au contrôle du plafond maximum
pour la rémunération des praticiens
intérimaires qui a fixé à 1390 euros par
vacation de 24 heures le montant j'ai eu
le 28 mars dernier à la demande du
directeur de l'ARS des Hauts-de-France
un échange téléphonique avec le
directeur adjoint en charge de mon
département ceci afin de faire le point
sur les établissements hospitaliers
susceptibles de rencontrer des
difficultés à la faveur de la mise en
œuvre de cette loi
l'assuenchère à laquelle était soumis
les directeurs d'établissements mais en
danger l'équilibre budgétaire de ceci
par son impact sur les dépenses de
personnel mais elle fragilise aussi la
stabilité des équipes médicales en place
en ouvrant de façon bien légitime une
question éthique ces nouvelles
dispositions n'ont pas vocation à mettre
un terme à l'intérêt dans le coup est
estimé à 1,5 milliards mais plutôt à
appeler tout le monde à la
responsabilité en rappelant avec force
les principes déontologiques liés à ces
professions j'en veux pour preuve
l’accueil favorable des grandes
fédérations hospitalières tant publique
que privé la réactivité de certains
établissements proposant d'ores et déjà
la possibilité de contrat à durée
déterminée si ce sujet a fait l'objet de
beaucoup d'inquiétudes voire de
réactions hostiles la majorité de nos
concitoyens attachés à notre système de
santé accueille cette disposition avec
satisfaction dans ce cont texte
avez-vous monsieur le ministre la
possibilité dans une dimension plus
large que celle de mon seul département
la possibilité d'éclairer notre
assemblée sur l'impact de celle-ci et
les éventuels remontées de terrain qui
sont à votre disposition merci pour vos
réponses la parole est communiste de la
santé de la prévention François Brown
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
monsieur le sénateur Dagbert je vous
remercie de relever ce gouvernement fait
bien appliquer la loi qui a été votée
par ce Parlement alors dans ce qui nous
concerne sur l'intérim et je reprends ce
que vous avez dit c'est bien la lutte
contre les dérives de cet intérim qui
est important c'est des rives qui certes
ont une incidence financière non
négligeable loin de là pour l'hôpital
mais surtout qui aboutissent à la
destruction de notre hôpital public quel
médecin voudra rester dans l'hôpital
public quand il voit à côté de lui un
collègue venir pour 24 heures et de
payer une fois et demie deux fois plus
que lui en un mois c'est donc une œuvre
essentielle pour la refonte de notre
système hospitalier mais ne va pas sans
la reconnaissance aussi en parallèle de
la pénibilité des carrières de ces
praticiens hospitaliers qui sont la
colonne vertébrale de notre service
public hospitalier c'est bien les deux
choses que nous devons mener de concert
c'est déjà le cas depuis les mesures qui
ont été pris cet été je prolonge les
discussions avec les syndicats de
praticiens hospitaliers pour justement
améliorer les conditions de travail des
praticiens à l'hôpital et faire revenir
tous ces praticiens à l'hôpital alors je
vous parle il n'y a pas de territoire
qui est laissé sans solution y compris
des zones qui étaient extrêmement
compliquées je pense aux maternité de
carré et de Landerneau par exemple ça
fait des mois voire des années qu'il y
avait des difficultés bien grâce à la
mobilisation des soignants à l'échelle
des territoires entre établissements et
je tiens là à le souligner grâce à
l'engagement des ARS nous avons pu
trouver des solutions quasiment partout
je dis quasiment parce qu'il existe des
points de difficultés qui existaient
avant cette mise en application pour
rester dans le sujet des maternités par
exemple la maternité de Sarlat ou celle
de Sedan qui est en difficulté avant
pour lesquelles
nous n'arrivons pas à avoir les
professionnels mais pour autant nous
avons mis en place des parcours de soins
pour les parturientes donc partout il y
a des solutions je suis cela de très
près avec les ARS deux fois par jour et
nous continuerons dans cette logique
territoriale à lutter inlassablement
contre les inégalités territoriales
d'accès à la santé je vous remercie la
parole est à notre collègue Corinne
Ferret pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
monsieur le ministre injuste
injustifiable imposé votre réforme des
retraites doit être retiré demain pour
la 11e journée de mobilisation des
centaines de milliers de Français
défileront partout dans le pays pour
exprimer une fois encore leur colère et
leur opposition à cette réforme après
deux mois d'un mouvement social
exemplaire et inédit depuis 50 ans très
largement soutenu par la population et
un parcours parlementaire s'est en a
fait par un 49.3 l'absence de réponse de
l'exécutif a conduit à une situation de
tension extrême dans le pays alors qu'il
aurait fallu jouer la carte du dialogue
social et de l'apaisement vous avez opté
pour le mépris l'essence sans réponse
pendant un mois la demande de
l'intersydicale au président de la
République d'être reçu en urgence ce
silence comme tout ce que vous avez fait
pendant des semaines pour empêcher un
vrai débat parlementaire en dit long sur
votre conception de la démocratie
sociale
alors que les Français sont toujours
plus nombreux à comprendre que vous avez
essayé de les berner madame la Première
ministre a daigné enfin ce matin
recevoir l'interse syndical ce fut de
toute évidence un échec alors Monsieur
le monsieur le ministre ne voyez-vous
pas que le pays s'enfonce dans une grave
crise démocratique
quand allez-vous entendre la colère qui
s'exprime quand allez-vous retirer cette
réforme
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail présent poids
monsieur Duce merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice Ferré je
ne reviendrai pas sur la rencontre de ce
matin j'ai dit en réponse à Madame la
signatrice Limal combien elle était
importante à nos yeux combien nous
sommes heureux qu'elle est puissent
tenir dans un état d'esprit respectueux
et combien nous sommes prêts avec madame
la Première ministre est-ce que sur tous
les sujets évoqués au-delà de la réforme
des retraites nous puissions avoir un
dialogue social le plus productif
possible vous dites madame la sénatrice
qu'il faudrait retirer la réforme
retirer la réforme madame la signatrice
ça signifie laisser les déficits de
s'accumuler il n'y a que vous qui
imaginez peut-être une seconde que
lorsqu'on met une réforme en pause les
déficits sont en pause il n'y a que vous
qui imaginez que si nous ne faisons pas
cette réforme aujourd'hui les marches
seraient plus facile à gravir dans deux
ans dans trois ans dans 4 ans ne pas
commencer ne pas faire cette réforme
madame la sénatrice ça signifie si vous
vous entenez au seul rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites ça signifie
un déficit qui s'accumule et ça signifie
des pensions de retraite qui décrochent
au niveau de vie moyenne des Français
nous ne souhaitons pas là pour des
retraités et nous le souhaitons pas que
le système puisse être englouti à sommet
par les déficits c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous agissons nous agissons et
nous le faisons d'autant plus que
chacune des alternatives qui nous a été
proposée chacune des contre-propositions
qui a été formulée y compris celles que
vous avez porté ce serait traduite par
une perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les
actifs Paris d'augmentation des
cotisations par une dégradation de la
compétitivité et par une perte d'emploi
ou alors par le creusement d'un déficit
qui aurait porté sur les générations
ultérieures j'ai souvenir madame les
sénatrices et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs du groupe socialiste j'ai
souvenir d'un esprit de responsabilité
en 2013 lorsque a été voté l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation un logement
que vous osez nous reprocher aujourd'hui
je l'ai voté et vous aussi je l'ai voté
en responsabilité et vous aussi cet
esprit de responsabilité vous a
désormais échappé
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez monsieur le ministre arrêtez de
vouloir noyer le poisson arrêter avec
les contre-vérités ça suffit les
Français en ont assez vous n'avez fait
le choix d'accentuer la crise
démocratique et sociale et nous n'avons
aucune leçon à recevoir de vous la
sagesse elle aurait été d'écouter les
Français on peut pas mettre les gens
autour de la table et dire d'emblée que
l'on continue à faire comme si de rien
n'était le dialogue social ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça parce que
encourager les fractures les tensions
dans un pays au bord de l'implosion ne
peut que mener au pire plus que jamais
il importe d'entendre et même de
consulter les Français nous avons
proposé d'organiser un référendum
d'initiative populaire alors donner la
parole au peuple serait véritablement
une voix d'apaisement
la parole est entre collègues Henri
Cabanel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues madame la
ministre dans un contexte de défiance
exacerbée envers les élus les turges de
resserrer les liens avec les citoyens le
dialogue à la monde des projets la
co-construction sont nécessaires mais il
est également
urgent de réinventer une culture
citoyenne notamment pour les jeunes qui
se sentent ni légitimes ni écouter ni
compris les chiffres de l'abstention en
témoignent j'ai été rapporteur d'une
mission à ce sujet présidée par mon
collègue Stéphane piénoir plusieurs
outils existent la journée de défense
est citoyenneté l'enseignement moral et
civique le service civique est celui
dont on parle beaucoup depuis plusieurs
mois le service national universel
généralisé obligatoire abandonné remis à
plus tard tous ces dit le constat
concernant ces outils et qu'il faut les
étudier en transversalité car ils sont
inter indépendants de nombreuses
informations ont été données sur le SNU
certaines fausses comme la
méditérisation des jeunes le SNU
généralisé génère des questions sur la
compétence des encadrants et des lieux
d'accueil et il faut se poser la
co-construction avec toutes les parties
prenantes notamment avec les jeunes le
service civique ayant fait ses preuves
il doit être poursuivi sur un long temps
il permet un réel engagement envers la
société avec à la clé un CV et une
ouverture sur le monde professionnel
madame la ministre comment envisé
envisagez-vous l'avenir de ce dispositif
et quid de la génération de la
généralisation pardon du fnu
un débat parlementaire a été préconisé
par notre mission
l'envisagez-vous et dans quel délai
pour vous répondre la parole qu'à madame
la secrétaire d'État chargée de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel Sarah
je cherche monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Cabanel vous avez
raison vous avez mille fois raison le
rapport qui préconisait plus de 23
mesures et tout à fait juste aujourd'hui
nous manquons d'une culture citoyenne
d'une culture citoyenne renforcée et
elle se construit elle se construit en
toute transversalité monsieur le
sénateur dans votre rapport
effectivement la mission d'information
présidée par le sénateur pied-noir mais
également en réalité complétée par le
rapport du sénateur Jean syntaxe sur la
question financière du service national
apporte un certain nombre de réponses la
culture citoyenne c'est d'abord une
culture commune ce sont des repères
communs c'est une aspiration à la nation
commune ça commence à l'école éducation
morale et civique ça passe par des
classes découvertes ça passe par la
reconnaissance de la démocratie scolaire
ça continue bien sûr avec la formation
de nos enseignants la redécouverte des
chantiers de patrimoine mais ça passe
aussi par la relation que nous avons
avec nos élus monsieur le sénateur plus
que jamais vous avez raison nos jeunes
de les urnes 9 jeunes sur dix ne se sont
pas déplacés aux dernières élections
régionales monsieur le sénateur plus que
jamais des conseils de jeunesse des
conseils municipaux de jeunes demain la
découverte au sein du service national
universel comme sorte de tant pivot de
temps fort mais non exclusif qui vient
compléter la journée défense et mémoire
les questions mémorielles que nous
portons avec ma collègue Patricia Mella
mirales nous permettront demain de
renforcer cette force mentale cette
force morale la jeunesse elle a besoin
d'avoir confiance dans nos institutions
elle a besoin qu'on lui donne des temps
de rencontre cette mixité elle doit être
sociale et territoriale et monsieur le
sénateur il se trouve que le SMU en ce
moment et je sais que ça touchera un
certain nombre de sénateurs et bien
permet aux jeunes ultramarins de venir
en métropole aux jeunes métropolitain
aux outre-mer des jeunes des territoires
ruraux de venir en zone plusieurs ben de
nos jeunes que demain un jeune d'une
zone périurbaine retrouve je crois la
beauté de nos territoires ruraux est une
chance cette chance elle mérite d'être
défend U et monsieur le sénateur je me
tiens à votre disposition pour les
débats parlementaires au sein des
groupes et des commissions je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Cabanel
oui merci Madame madame la ministre mais
voilà dans le rapport comme vous l'avez
cité nous préconisons un débat un débat
parlementaire on ne veut pas se priver
de ce débat essentiel pour pour notre
jeunesse car le SNU le service civique
et les autres outils peuvent et doivent
devenir un outil d'intégration sociale
et d'éducation à la citoyenneté
la parole est à notre collègue Jacques
ferrique pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre Hervé
Berville dimanche vous avez crânement
proclamé avoir fait reculer Bruxelles
sur l'interdiction du chalutage de fond
dans les air marines protégées non non
vous n'avez pas fait plier la Commission
européenne puisque dès le départ son
plan d'action n'était pas contraignant
en racontant aux pécheurs que la
Commission allait je vous cite condamné
la pêche artisanale française dès demain
vous avez joué un jeu dangereux vous
avez aggravé un climat déjà électrique à
l'encontre des défenseurs de
l'environnement c'est gonflé je crois
monsieur le ministre de ce prévaloir de
la cause de la pêche artisanale pour
soutenir en fait le chalutage industriel
de fond c'est un peu comme si on
subventionnait Amazon en prétendant
défendre les commerces de proximité nos
pécheurs n'ont pas besoin d'une telle du
prix ils ont besoin d'écosystème en bon
état si nous voulons pouvoir encore
pêcher dans 23 ans vos airs marine
protégées sont-elles des supercheries
quand la Commission européenne a
recommandé d'y cesser le chalutage de
fond vous avez été pris à votre propre
jeu de ducs vous avez vu une occasion de
vous ériger en héros de la pêche
artisanale fallait osée fallait oser
alors que vous laissez des chalutiers
géants détruire la pêche côtière alors
que vous vous opposez à la demande de
nos pêcheurs d'interdire la scène des
mersal près des côtes alors oui les
pêcheurs sont en colère ils refusent la
case sociale sans solution durable on ne
parviendra pas à un apaisement nous ne
voulons pas qu'un incendie comme celui
de l'Office français de la biodiversité
à Brest se reproduisent alors Monsieur
le Ministre plutôt que de pointer du
doigt les défenseurs de l'environnement
de le stigmatiser comme certains sciais
à fond et sur tous les fronts ces
derniers temps à quand une cohérence
entre vos déclarations et vos actes
donc vous répondre à parler au
secrétaire d'État chargé de la mer
rvberville monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Fernique alors désolé de vous
le dire mais je ne sais pas où est-ce
que vous êtes allé pêcher tout ça mais
c'est purement et simplement faux je
vais pas indiqué que la Commission avait
reculé j'ai indiqué qu'elle avait
confirmé ce que je vous avais dit ici au
Sénat le 8 mars c'est que c'était un
plan une communication et que vous
n'avez pas vocation à être traduit en
acte législatif écoutez ce qui se dit au
Sénat ici ensuite deuxième élément la
Commission européenne devant les
parlementaires européens avaient indiqué
qu'elle avait l'intention peut-être de
le traduire en acte et donc quand c'est
flou c'est parfois il y a un loup et
donc j'ai demandé à la Commission
européenne quand je me suis rendu au
Conseil européen d'avoir la confirmation
que oui en effet tout ça n'était laissé
qu'à la main des États membres ensuite
vous parlez des armées protégées ça me
permet de clarifier les choses vous
étiez responsabilité vous avez vous-même
créé des aires marines protégées entre
2012 et 2004 est-ce que tout y était
interdit non car le code de
l'environnement prévoit qu'il a 14 types
d'air marines protégées de la réserve
intégrale où on ne peut rien faire
aucune activité humaine à des airs
marine protégées où il peut y avoir des
activités de pêche et tous les élus
locaux ici littoraux le savent très bien
nous pouvons avoir des activités de
pêche qui sont vertueuses qui permettent
de protéger l'habitat marin et ma
position est celle de l'ensemble des
élus locaux des façades littorales a été
une position de cohérence nous avons
fait la démonstration depuis 20 ans en
France qu'on peut avoir une pêche
côtière artisanale est-ce que vous
pensez que les pêcheurs à la coquille
ravagent la planète non est-ce que vous
pensez que les producteurs d'huîtres
pensez que les pêcheurs la langoustine
ravage la planète non or s'il avait une
traduction législative c'est ce qui
aurait abouti la fin de cette page
artisanale donc nous nous assumons de
continuer à défendre la pêche artisanale
la pêche côtière et donc nous assumons
de continuer à avoir dans des zones près
de nos côtes cette pratique d'une pêche
qui est vertueuse qui a fait ses preuves
et qu'il faut continuer à pousser à
défendre et c'est ce que nous allons
faire avec vous les élus locaux
[Applaudissements]
votre communiqué suite au 1er avril ce
n'est quand même comme un communiqué de
victoire un poisson d'avril un peu
décalé je crois qu'il va falloir penser
à la transition vous pouvez pas rejeter
en bloc tout évolution sur les chats du
tâches de fond sur les aires marines
protégées ça ne sera pas tenable où sont
les mesures structurelles pour nos
pécheurs artisanaux pour une pêche
durable socialement vivable protéger le
statu quo ce serait à terme les coulé
la parole est à notre collègue Franck
Menonville pour le groupe Les
Indépendants Républiques et territoires
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
près de 4000 élus ont démissionné depuis
le début de leur mandat en 2020 le seuil
de millemer démissionnaires est dépassé
annoncé ce lundi le président de l'AMF
dans un entretien au Figaro cette vague
de démission est sans précédent et c'est
très inquiétant pour mon département de
la Meuse on démembre en dénombre la
démission de 10 mères 64 adjoints 207
conseillers un président de Codecom et
un vice-président les élus sont le
maillon de proximité de la vaste chaîne
des acteurs de l'intérêt général dans
notre République ils sont positionnés en
première ligne face aux nombreux défis
actuels pourtant ils exercent leur
mission dans un climat parfois délétère
il voit leur pouvoir se diluer
progressivement notamment avec les
transferts de compétences il subissent
les complexités administratives et les
lurdeurs de bureaucratiques pesante qui
entravent leur action sans oublier
l'importance des responsabilités qui
leur incombe il est de plus en plus
difficile à concilier l'exercice du
mandat avec une vie professionnelle et
personnelle cela implique donc de
nombreux sacrifices nous pouvons ajouter
les actes d'intimidation et les
agressions vers les élus qui se
multiplient ces derniers temps nous
observons avec inquiétude la radicalité
les montées de l'individualisme et le
durcissement croissant de la société
poscovid les causes qui déprécient
l'attractivité du mandat local sont
multiples monsieur le ministre a trois
ans des prochaines élections municipales
prévues en 2026 il est urgent d'adresser
un message de confiance à nos élus
locaux et d'engager une vaste réflexion
sur leur statut dès lors quelle
initiative comptez-vous prendre pour
restaurer l'attractivité de cet
engagement
revaloriser concrètement le mandat
municipal à 3 ans du renouvellement
pour vous répondre la parole au ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur Béchu
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Menonville merci pour cette question
c'est le nombre très exact de maire non
pas qui ont cessé leur fonction parce
que on intègre évidemment pas les décès
mais le nombre de démissions de maires
depuis le début du mandat il faut
toujours se méfier des chiffres
parce que sur les 6 ans entre 2014 et
2020 ce sont 2925 mères qui avaient des
missionné et on est donc sur des
moyennes comparables de l'ordre de 40
par mois
mais on est qu'à la moitié du mandat et
on a eu beaucoup de démission en tout
début de mandat dans certainement qui
sont liés au covid à un contexte
d'entrée dans la fonction qui a été
compliqué je le vois dans mon
département avec des équipes municipales
ou la mayonnaise n'a pas prise parce
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps et l'occasion
de travailler ensemble mais pour autant
la conjoncture explique pas tout il y a
la montée de la violence et je veux
saluer à la fois la loi engagement et
proximité qui a permis en 2019 de
renforcer la protection fonctionnelle et
le texte récent défendu par Eric
Dupont-Moretti et par Gérald Darmanin
porté par le RDSE et qui permet de faire
en sorte de permettre de mieux tenir
compte de mieux répondre avec les
constitutions de partie civile des
associations il faut évidemment aller
plus loin et de ce point de vue il y a
deux moments qui vont compter d'abord je
me tourne vers le président d'Arnaud
parce qu'il y a la mission sur l'avenir
de la commune et du maire que la chambre
haute de l'assemblée
se pose la question qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire quels sont les leviers sur
lesquels on peut jouer essaye
d'objectiver ces chiffres dont je
parlais il y a quelques instants c'est
souhaitable et c'est précieux et puis
enfin la semaine prochaine
Elisabeth born recevra l'ensemble des
associations d'élus dont David star avec
lequel nous avons commencé déjà à
discuter de cette question et la
question du statut de l'élu dans
l'agenda territorial que nous porterons
avec Dominique Faure dans la continuité
de ces échanges sera évidemment un des
sujets qui va rythmer dans les prochains
mois la vie démocratique de notre pays
les mers se sont les fantassins de la
République ils sont à portée de bave de
nos concitoyens ils assument toutes les
missions ils portent toutes les
responsabilités le moment est venu de
regarder comment on peut mieux les
accompagner
la parole à notre collègue Stéphane Le
Rue dulier pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de la Justice ces dernières
heures la guerre des gangs sur fond de
trafic de drogue ferrage à Marseille
avec trois morts trois morts de plus et
on se dirige malheureusement vers un
nouveau record après les 39 morts en
c'est règlement de compte ont déjà fait
plus de 300 morts en 10 ans trois
sormons 300 morts qui font du vieux port
et de Marseille un nouveau Medellin une
nouvelle French Connection Marseille est
aujourd'hui l'otage des cartels et
pourtant pourtant les moyens
sécuritaires ont été mis en oeuvre plus
de 300 policiers supplémentaires trois
compagnies de CRS 39 points de deal de
démanteler c'est une guerre d'usure et
non pas une guerre éclair certes mais là
où nos forces de l'ordre combattent au
quotidien ces cartels la justice et
l'arsenal juridique semble marquer le
pas alors monsieur le ministre de la
Justice pensez-vous que la réponse
pénale est à la hauteur de la stratégie
de déstabilisation des réseaux menés par
les forces de l'ordre
pour vous répondre
la parole est à au ministre de
l'intérieur
des Outre-mer monsieur Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Madame
remplacer monsieur Miss de la justice
mais je parle évidemment au nom du
gouvernement pour saluer l'engagement
d'abord de nos forces de l'ordre vous
l'avez dit je vous remercie de le saluer
qui tous les jours à Marseille ailleurs
mais particulièrement à Marseille ville
à la fois magnifique mais depuis très
longtemps vous le savez quand grainé par
le trafic de drogue les policiers et les
gendarmes tous les jours interviennent
dans tous les quartiers de Marseille
toutes les demi-heurs font des
opérations antidrogue et depuis le 1er
janvier à Marseille monsieur sénateur
mais vous connaissez bien ce territoire
une tonne de cannabis en trois mois
saisi 509 interpellations de trafiquants
ce qui montre l'activité des quasiment
500 policiers pérède que nous avons mis
à la demande du Président de la
République la Premier ministre à
Marseille depuis deux ans et qui
agissent en effet en une guerre d'usure
il faut faire davantage et notamment
vous l'avez dit il faut que la justice
puisse suivre cette activité de police
extrêmement importante de police
judiciaire mais aussi de police de
sécurité publique et le garde des sceaux
hier la semaine nationale a précisé les
moyens très importants qu'il met à
Marseille particulièrement auprès du
parquet de Marseille qui suit
particulièrement ces dossiers de trafic
de stupéfiants mais aussi de magistrats
de judiciaire également de greffiers
c'est une centaine de magistrats tout
confondu rien que pour Marseille qui
accompagne nous le croyons que le garder
sceaux le travail que nous faisons en
commun mais il y a évidemment le fils
qui a évidemment la douane il y a
évidemment aussi ce que peut faire la
ville de Marseille et sa métropole pour
aider la police et la gendarmerie aime
mieux intervenir dans un certain nombre
de quartier puis il y a les moyens
législatifs dont nous avons besoin j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire ce matin encore
devant la commission des lois et dans le
président de la commission des lois et
dans la sénateur que l'une des
difficultés de la police et de
gendarmerie c'est que les écoutes
téléphoniques à la papa pardon de le
dire comme ça fonctionne mal puisque
aujourd'hui les gens passent par
Internet par des applications cryptées
et que nous n'avons pas la possibilité
le droit de nous le permet pas d'écouter
ces conversations cryptées ce que nous
pouvons faire en terrorisme et qui
montre son efficacité est-ce que vous
pouvez pas faire pour le banditisme je
soumets à votre assemblée cette sagacité
cette réflexion pour aider encore la
police s'agissait être plus efficace sur
le rut du liée
merci merci monsieur le ministre de
votre réponse évidemment je pense qu'il
faut améliorer la chaîne chaîne pénale
notamment les places de prison notamment
le fait de ne pas proliférer de non-lieu
ou de classement sans suite parce que ça
procure au Sentier un sentiment de
superpuissance au narcos trafiquants
kinésitent plus maintenant à tuer des
mineurs mais je comprends votre
détermination mais je suis plus inquiet
par rapport au ministre de la Justice
qui déclarait il y a peu qui
n'existaient pas de coupe-gorge en
France et je l'invite bien volontiers à
Marseille car il existe bien pire encore
des narcosités qui ont fait la sécession
et où la kalachnikov a remplacé Marianne
avec un usage débridé des armes à feu je
vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue Laurence
Blatterie compta pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le S metola
chlore herbicides agricole utilisé pour
de nombreuses cultures de printemps
notamment le maïs à un impact avéré sur
la qualité de l'eau et notre
environnement c'est produit de
dégradation s'accumulent dans les nappes
phréatiques pendant des dizaines
d'années depuis le 1er janvier 2021 les
métabolites du S métolaclore font partie
des molécules recherchées dans l'eau
mise en distribution et de nombreuses
collectivités ont été confrontées à des
dépassements réguliers de la norme et un
million six de nos concitoyens sont
concernés l'un des principaux fabricants
de ce produit a d'ailleurs indiqué que
ces produits ne devaient pas être
utilisés dans les parcelles situées dans
les airs d'alimentation de captage d'eau
en juin dernier l'agent européenne des
produits chimiques à classer cette
herbicide comme substance cancérigènes
et perturbateurs endocriniens suspectés
saisit en 2021 par les trois directions
générales de l'alimentation la
prévention des risques et de la santé
l'ancêtre a rendu plusieurs études
inquiétantes et le 15 février dernier
lands a logiquement annoncé engager une
procédure de retrait concernant cet
herbicide or à la veille la présentation
du plan o par le Président de la
République le ministre de l'Agriculture
a annoncé devant le congrès de la FNSEA
avoir demandé à l'ancêtre de revenir sur
sa volonté d'interdire les principaux
usages du S métola clore monsieur le
ministre au titre de la souveraineté
alimentaire que nous appelons tous de
nos vœux mais qui a parfois bandeau
quand il est question de l'usage des
pesticides comptez-vous réellement jouer
avec la santé de nos concitoyens en
revenant sur la décision de lancès de
retirer le S métola clore est-ce
compatible avec le plan o visant à
protéger la ressource en eau
pour vous répondre la parole est
le ministre porte-parole de gouvernement
Monsieur Olivier Véran
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
Florence blatrix comptable j'excuse le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui est
actuellement avec le président de la
République en déplacement en Chine et je
vais donc tâcher de répondre à sa place
à votre question d'abord vous dire que
nous partageons madame la sénatrice
l'envie de nous débarrasser des
pesticides qui ont un impact sur la
santé des gens vous l'avez dit vous-même
il est suspecté il est pas avéré mais il
est suspecté donc le principe de
précaution doit l'emporter comme c'est
le cas avec toutes les substances qui
peuvent avoir un impact sur la santé
c'est d'ailleurs le sens de l'histoire
et c'est le sens de travail que conduit
la France et que conduit l'Europe ce que
je crois comprendre en matière
s'agissant de ce pesticides de cette
substances en particulier c'est que vous
l'avez cité l'enjeu de souveraineté
alimentaire mais il y a aussi l'enjeu
qui consiste à être capable d'avancer en
européen sur ces questions que la France
n'est pas unie Lexi la France était le
seul pays de l'Union européenne à
interdire une substance on se
retrouverait dans la situation
abracadabrantesque ou la France
importerait d'autres pays européens des
produits alimentaires parce qu'elle
serait plus capable de produire
elle-même ces aliments parce qu'elle
n'aurait pu les substances pour pouvoir
la cultiver notre bonne condition et
donc un portrait à grand frais les mêmes
produits qui eux aurait été subis soumis
au même substance chez les pays voisins
donc on veut y arriver il y a l'Europe
je crois donne un délai je vais pas vous
dire de bêtises mais de
ça doit être de deux ou trois ans pour
pouvoir y parvenir et c'est bien la
volonté française de manière générale
que de se passer de toutes les
substances qui peuvent avoir un impact
je vous le redis sur la santé c'est un
objectif partagé
monsieur le ministre rien ne sert de
reporter c'est une question de santé
publique et il est urgent de travailler
aux alternatives pour les agriculteurs
et donc à leur résilience et je crois
que nous avons finalement une occasion
de prendre de l'avance sur nos
partenaires européens
la parole est à notre collègue Anne
chalarcher pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le président
monsieur ma question
s'intérior monsieur Darmanin en
septembre la France accueille la Coupe
du monde de rugby et en août 2024 les JO
10 millions de passagers supplémentaires
sont attendus dans nos aéroports surtout
à Roissy Charles-de-Gaulle vaisseau
amiral du groupe ADP rappelez-vous le
groupe ADP c'est cette entreprise que
Bruno Le Maire voulait à tout prix
privatiser en 2019 pour payer la facture
des gilets jaunes et bien elle devrait
rapporter plus de 150 millions d'euros
de dividendes à l'État actionnaire pour
2022 nous avons bien fait de nous
opposer à sa privatisation
mais revenons à l'avenir proche ma
question concerne l'organisation des
contrôles aux frontières à Roissy
Charles-de-Gaulle ou arrive les vols
longs courriers vous en avez la
responsabilité on nous parle d'embauche
à venir mais 355 postes de policiers aux
frontières ont été supprimés on nous
parle d'automatisation mais les SAS
paraphes ces bornes qui lisent les
passeports biométriques ne sont pas
assez nombreux et sont souvent fermés
faute de personnels pour les surveiller
résultat il y a parfois jusqu'à deux
heures d'attente oui deux heures pour
passer la frontière belle première image
de la France face à de décès
désorganisation ces voyageurs étrangers
au fort pouvoir d'achat préféreront
atterrir à Bruxelles ou Francfort et
regagné Paris en train l'attractivité de
la France est menacée car elle n'est pas
prête à faire face on se dirige vers une
pagaille qui risque de ternir encore
plus l'image de notre pays monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour
améliorer l'accueil des visiteurs
étrangers
dans nos aéroports
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les 700 je partage avec vous
le souci de bien accueillir les
personnes étrangères qui arrivent
notamment de long courrier notamment tôt
le matin c'est le cas de vol qui
viennent de l'Asie ou qui viennent des
Amériques lorsqu'ils arrivent dans les
aéroports et notamment parisiens et
singulièrement à Roissy Charles de
Gaulle est-ce qu'aujourd'hui l'accueil
est parfait non il ne l'est pas et cette
responsabilité est partagée entre le
groupe Aéroport de Paris et la police
aux frontières comme vous l'avez évoqué
la difficulté que nous avons c'est qu'en
effet la mise en place d'un certain
nombre de traitements automatisés des
passeports qu'on appelle le système
paraphe est en nombre insuffisant et la
première décision prise par ADP que de
soutenons c'est 40% de paraff en plus
une cinquantaine qui seront installés
d'ici cet été ce qui est une très bonne
chose notamment pour la Coupe du monde
de rugby deuxièmement y a-t-il assez de
personnes qui pour le ministère d'un
tailleur contrôle l'arrivée des
personnes pour le point de vue de
sécurité non il pas assez 510 personnes
sont en cours de recrutement 300
d'ailleurs d'ici à la fin du mois
d'avril et si le mois d'avril est à moi
encore compliqué à passer bien
évidemment et nous le renforçons par des
policiers venus de l'extérieur cet été
j'en prends l'engagement les choses se
passeront au mieux et la publication
désormais a été décidée chaque semaine
de connaître le temps d'attente
terminale par terminal pour que chacun
puisse vérifier des choses troisièmement
madame je pense que la réponse n'est pas
le renforcement forcément de policiers
aux frontières la police aux frontières
ce sont des femmes et des zones de
police nationale formés qui portent une
arme et qui mérite d'être de faire des
choses parfois plus importantes pour le
territoire national comme la reconduite
des personnes dans leur pays d'origine
en revanche qui est du personnel civile
du ministère de l'Intérieur formé à la
fraude documentaire à au consultation
des fichiers contractuels qui nous
permet de les embaucher plus rapidement
encore et notamment c'est le cas en
Seine-Saint-Denis dans l'ensemble
Île-de-France oui c'est ce que nous
faisons cette transformation très forte
donc vous avez compris je partage votre
souci votre constat et avec ADP avec la
police aux frontières nous faisons tout
pour être prêt non pas pour la Coupe du
monde mais dès le mois de mai de cette
année
monsieur
ministre nous demandons bien sûr qu'à
vous croire maintenant il faut faire
attention car la France fait peur aux
visiteurs étrangers je pense qu'il faut
prendre conscience de la terrible
vitrine que nous offrons au monde entier
sainte Soline les émeutes les grèves les
mairies et les CRS en flammes les
manifestations les Black Blocs elle est
bien loin notre douce France
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Nadia sur
le gouv pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le président
IAL son prédécesseur déclarait le 27
mars 2020 on est dans de telles
circonstances exceptionnelles que les
fermetures de classe qui se prévoient en
ce moment nous les revoyons il ne doit
pas y avoir de querelles entre quiconque
sur ces sujets actuellement les
circonstances exceptionnelles dont
parlait Jean-Michel Blanquer c'était la
crise sanitaire en avril 2023 nous
vivons une autre crise profonde tout
aussi exceptionnelle qui est aussi celle
des territoires et de la ruralité et il
faut y apporter des réponses
exceptionnelles
dans ce contexte vendredi à Nevers où
j'ai eu le plaisir de vous accueillir
madame la Première ministre vous avez
fait des annonces les fermetures seront
désormais je vous cite prévu trois ans à
l'avance afin de laisser Homer le temps
de s'organiser je ne vous cache pas ma
déception car ce n'est pas ce que
j'espérais aussi je veux renouvelle
publiquement ma question quel message
adressez-vous au maire qui en avril 2023
désemparé déçu pour certains tentés par
la démission dans un contexte local et
national particulièrement compliqué
espère encore que vous ne fermerez pas
leur 1500 classes je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et de la
ministre déléguée chargée de
l'enseignement et la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice solo goub je tiens déjà à
présenter les excuses de Monsieur le
Ministre l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse qui est retenue à l'Assemblée
nationale pour un débat madame la
sénatrice je voudrais rappeler au
préalable deux chiffres moi 300000
élèves c'est le nombre d'élèves en moins
sur ces cinq dernières années et moins
500 000 élèves à prévoir entre 2022 et
2027 cette réalité madame la ministre
l'a évidemment exprimé vendredi dernier
dans votre département qui accompagnait
par les ministres papendaye et Dominique
Faure à justement pu échanger avec les
enseignants les élèves et les élus sur
la question de l'école et notamment
l'école en ruralité une fermeture de
classe évidemment a un impact
particulièrement prononcé dans les
communes rurales et c'est ce que la
première ministre a souhaité échanger
avec nouveaux acteurs la première
ministre a annoncé effectivement la
méthode une méthode permettant une
anticipation sur trois années permettant
un dialogue avec les élus pour organiser
cette démographie en baisse qui partout
en France a évidemment un impact sur
l'organisation de l'école sur le
territoire je voudrais dire que cette
anticipation bien sûr elle elle est avec
une conséquence qui est tout à fait
favorable sur le taux d'encadrement et
je permet de le rappeler ces 5,46 élèves
qui pour 100
5,46 pardon enseignant pour 100 élèves
en 2017 alors qu'on est à 18 en 2023 et
bien que les élus du département et
vous-même avaient effectivement
interpellé ministres l'éducation
nationale je me permets de rappeler que
vous n'avez aucune classe à moins de 24
élèves dans votre département et que
nous avons décidé de maintenir trois
classes sur ce département c'est bien
sûr une volonté que nous souhaitons
étendre à tout le territoire une méthode
qui permet l'anticipation et encore une
fois un dialogue avec les élus du
département nous prenons évidemment en
compte la question des écoles en milieu
rural et tenons à effectivement la
qualité de l'enseignement sur l'ensemble
du territoire
au contraire on pourrait avoir moins
d'enfants par classe s'il y avait moins
de professeurs encore ce serait dans
l'autre sens mais dans ce sens-là je ne
comprends pas et en ce qui concerne le
taux d'encadrement je veux vous rappelle
que nous sommes les plus mauvais élèves
d'Europe puisque avec 24 élèves par
classe ce sont les pires taux qui
puissent exister la moyenne étant plutôt
autour de 22 et quand à cette
organisation qui ressent plus à une
forme de programmation trigonale de
fermeture je vous assure qu'elle ne
vient absolument pas en aide des élus
d'ailleurs regrouper des classes dans
tous les sens ça veut dire mettre des
enfants sur la route organiser des
transports scolaires c'est un coup
supplémentaire c'est beaucoup
d'organisations beaucoup de fatigue pour
les enfants donc vraiment donner
n'ajoutez pas des manifestations
manifestations ni de la colère à la
colère donner une année de respiration
donner un geste d'apaisement je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue Véronique
del Favreau pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues pour être très
précise c'est 4751 élus qui ont
raccroché leur écharpe tricolore depuis
le début du mandat de 2020 les chiffres
sont ce qu'ils sont n'empêche que 275
mères 913 adjoints
3563 élus municipaux estimé qu'il y
avait trop d'ennuis trop de complexité
trop de violences physiques et morales
pour continuer sereinement à exercer
leur mandat trois quarts de ses
démissions ont eu lieu dans des communes
de moins de 1500 habitants l'engagement
public Madame le Ministre attire de
moins en moins et ce n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour notre démocratie de plus
en plus d'élules locaux expriment leurs
difficultés au quotidien pour exercer
leur fonction à la fois animateur d'une
équipe municipale l'employeur du
personnel communal garant des données
publics gestionnaire de crise médiateurs
comptables de fermeture de classe il
s'interroge sur leur avenir ces élus
locaux jettent l'éponge face à
l'inflation documentaire et législatives
le code général des collectivités
territoriales à triplé en 20 ans
certains élus parlent de harcèlement
textuels ces élus locaux jettent
l'éponge face à la baisse des dotations
face à la faiblissement
organisé de leur ressources aux réformes
successives c'est les élus locaux
jettent l'éponge face au manque de
considération du plus haut niveau de
l'État pour le mandat le paternalisme
d'État exaspérant les mères aspira un
peu plus de liberté un petit peu moins
de contraintes inutiles madame le
ministre je suis sûr que vous êtes
consciente de ces difficultés mais
comment allez-vous y remédier
[Applaudissements]
en charge des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité madame
Dominique Faure
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice delfabro Alors comme mes
collègues ministres Gérald Darmanin et
Christophe bichu j'ai eu la chance et
vous le savez d'exercer le mandat de
maire pendant près de 10 ans et c'est
pour moi un des plus beaux mandats de
notre République dans ce contexte social
agité je veux tout d'abord réaffirmer
mon soutien notre soutien sans faille à
tous les parlementaires et à tous les
élus locaux qui ont subi des agressions
ces dernières semaines chaque jour la
liste s'allonge et c'est inacceptable en
ce qui concerne la démission des maires
depuis juillet j'ai rencontré
personnellement et depuis début juillet
plus de mille élus locaux qui me
témoignent aussi leur bonheur d'être
mère mais il ne faut pas le nier
il y a un malaise une lassitude dans
l'exercice de leur fonction ce sentiment
a récemment été très bien décrit par le
président de l'AMF David Lisnard que je
tiens ici à saluer dans sa mobilisation
pour ce sujet je sais mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que vous êtes
également très impliqués sur ce sujet au
travers de la mission d'information sur
l'avenir de la commune et du maire
présidé par la sénatrice Maryse Carrère
le gouvernement l'est aussi la loi
engagement est proximité par exemple
permet en 2019 la revalorisation des
indemnités des maires et des adjoints
des plus petites communes vous l'avez
cité j'ai bien conscience qu'une
nouvelle évolution est plus que
nécessaire et qu'elle doit dépasser le
cadre statutaire à ce mal profond auquel
je ne peux me résoudre nous devons
apporter une réponse forte je reçois et
j'échange avec des mères démissionnaires
pour en comprendre les causes de la
façon la plus précise possible au-delà
de celle que vous avez citées et que je
partage
dans les prochaines semaines je ferai
une proposition pour engager avec les
élus locaux les associations d'élus la
MF la MRF vous aussi parlementaire dans
une démarche large et concertée pour
bâtir une feuille de route commune sur
la place de l'élu local au sein de notre
République et au sein de notre société
je crois fermement que l'avenir de notre
démocratie repose sur les mers ils sont
le visage ils sont le ciment ils sont le
pilier de notre République je vous
remercie
je vous remercie beaucoup pour votre
réponse vous
dites il y a à peine trois mois j'étais
encore mère d'une commune de moins de
350 habitants le statut c'est important
mais ce n'est pas suffisant
les mères aspirent à plus d'autonomie à
plus de liberté dans ce cas là on
comprend pas très bien pourquoi il est
attiser la tarification de l'eau comme
le président de la République l'a
annoncé on ne comprend pas très bien la
multiplication de tous ces schémas
directeurs alors madame Lamine je
l'espère faites confiance à tous ces
élus
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
meunier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
Solidarités monsieur le ministre je ne
vous parlerai pas de fin de vie ni de
fin de carrière professionnelle même si
ce sujet préoccupe les Françaises et les
Français je parlerai de la fin du mois
des plus précaires d'entre eux RSA
allocation adulte handicapées minimum
vieillesse les minima sociaux ont été
revalorisés de
1,6%, le 1er avril dernier après une
hausse de 4% l'année dernière en juillet
en comparaison à la hausse du coût de la
vie c'est loin d'être suffisant les plus
modestes subissent une inflation de plus
de 7% en un an et le budget alimentaire
c'est même supérieur à plus de 14%. les
dépenses du budget d'un ménage d'une
femme seule avec deux enfants augmente
de 170 euros par mois et ces prestations
il y a location elle vous demande de 17
euros par mois 10 fois moins la sonnette
d'alarme a été tirée par le collectif
Alerte qui comme vous le savez FEDER 34
organisation de lutte contre les
exclusions elle souhaite l'indexation
des minima sociaux sur les budgets de
référence des ménage modestes comme les
calculs est fait pour le SMIC elle les
exige dans l'immédiat une hausse de 5%
des minima sociaux monsieur le ministre
que leur répondez vous
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste des solidarités de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
monsieur Combes merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Michel
meunier je vous remercie pour votre
question parce qu'elle me permet de
rappeler que depuis le depuis 18 mois le
gouvernement agissant relâche pour
lutter contre l'inflation et en
particulier contre l'inflation à la
racine avec le bouclier tarifaire sur
l'énergie avec l'ensemble des mesures
qui ont été prises pour maîtriser
l'inflation vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis des
Français les prix ont accéléré au cours
de l'été 2022 ils vous l'avez dit nous
avons pris la décision de revaloriser de
façon anticipée les minima sociaux de 4%
parce que les plus modestes ont été les
plus exposés à l'augmentation des prix à
la rentrée scolaire 2022 nous avons
distribué une aide exceptionnelle de
solidarité de 160 euros en moyenne par
ménage à la rentrée et nous avons
continué les prix les prix pétroliers
ont été les plus dynamiques à augmenter
cette fin d'année nous avons mis en
place un chèque énergie de sang à 200
euros par ménage et vous l'avez dit à
partir d'avril depuis le 1er avril les
prestations sociales ont été
revalorisées de plus de 5,6% sur 12 mois
c'est le niveau d'inflation calculer
strictement par l'INSEE au cours de ces
12 derniers mois et donc jusqu'à présent
notre réponse face à l'inflation a été à
la hauteur et a permis de protéger les
Français face à la Hauser prix et en
particulier les plus modestes en 2023
on a un défi majeur c'est celle de la
poursuite de cette inflation en
particulier sur les prix de
l'alimentation c'est pour ça que nous
avons pris nos responsabilités et lancer
le trimestre anti-inflation pour
permettre un accès aux produits de
première nécessité dans les supermarchés
c'est pour ça également que nous avons
mis en place le programme mieux manger
pour tous pour permettre un accès au
ménage les plus modestes à des produits
de qualité puisqu'on sait que ce sont
les produits qui sont arbitrés en
premier par ces ménages les plus modest
es je pense aux fruits et légumes à la
viande aux poissons bref à tous les
produits de qualité dont les Français
ont besoin j'ai réuni il y a quelques
jours l'ensemble des associations de
solidarité pour faire le point avec eux
et nous nous reverrons dans deux mois
pour faire un point sur la situation et
prendre les mesures nécessaires si la
situation perdure
nous sommes loin du compte et pour
répondre à cette crise il faut des
politiques publiques de redistribution
et de sortie de la précarité cette
incompatible avec la politique fiscale
de votre gouvernement qui concentre les
baisses d'impôts sur les entreprises et
plus aisées des Français on savait cette
politique dangereuse pour le climat et
on la sait maintenant aussi alarmante
pour le climat social
la parole est à notre collègue elle se
Joseph pour le groupe les républicains
seul président sur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues notre
pays subit en matière de santé un
véritable désaménagement du territoire
avec une fracture territoriale qui ne
cesse de s'accroître ce problème existe
depuis plus de 20 ans et concerne de
manière dramatique toutes les formes de
l'exercice médical en France mais ce
sujet n'a pas fait l'objet d'un moindre
programme du président de la République
pendant sa campagne si nous sommes
sensibles aux excès produit par les
fonctions intérimaires à l'hôpital la
loiriste risque d'augmenter et
d'aggraver la problématique des déserts
médicaux dans certaines régions nous
manquons cruellement de médecins
d'anesthésiste de gynécologue de
psychiatre et bien au-delà certains
habitants en France sont en grand danger
de perte de chance et de manque de soins
et surtout dans notre ruralité un récent
en rapport remis à l'Académie de
médecine envisage la suppression d'une
centaine de maternité pour tout
établissement pratiquant moins de 1000
accouchements la maternité de Sedan dans
les Ardennes est ainsi visée
et il a été annoncé la suspension
provisoire d'activités des accouchements
par manque de professionnels
cette invitation aux fermeture de
maternité repose sur un critère
arbitraire elle se nourrit d'une vision
purement comptable de la médecine et
d'une approche réductrice de ce qu'est
une naissance certes vous avez augmenté
numerus clausus mais le nombre de places
dans les facultés n'augmente pas comme
il le faudrait et dans certaines
spécialités les choix que vous faites en
matière de répartition des places
d'internat ne sont pas toujours
judicieux et aggravent le phénomène la
situation et l'avenir de la maternité de
ce dont ne nous rassure pas les appels à
la réserve sanitaire sont aujourd'hui
infructueux nette ne doit pas devenir un
soin difficile et un parcours du
combattant mais rester un apport un
moment important et secure monsieur le
ministre quand on dit vous faire pour
que la santé des femmes et de leurs
enfants ne soient pas sacrifiées sur
l'hôtel de la comptabilité au nom de
conception technocratique qui ont déjà
tant fragilisé notre pays quand visage
vous pour que nous ne passions pas d'une
suspension provisoire à une suspension
définitive et n'avoir plus ainsi qu'une
seule maternité dans le département des
Ardennes la situation est extrêmement
grave et je peux vous dire que les
Français la ressentent merci pour vos
réponses la parole est communiste de la
santé de la prévention
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Joseph effectivement lutter
contre les inégalités territoriales
d'accès à la santé est une de mes
priorités vous le savez très bien pour
autant il faut dire la vérité et dire
continuellement la vérité au français
nous n'aurons pas 10 000 médecins de
plus demain au claquant des doigts
heureusement lors du mandat précédent le
numerus clausus a été déverrouillé ce
qui a permis déjà aujourd'hui d'avoir
15% de médecins de plus qui rentrent en
deuxième année de médecine pour autant
vous le savez comme moi il faut 10 ans
pour faire un médecin donc nous n'aurons
pas de résultats en termes d'effectif
demain même si même si nous travaillons
en permanence pour augmenter cette
disponibilité de temps médical en
s'appuyant entre autres sur les autres
professionnels de santé et
particulièrement les sages-femmes en ce
qui concerne les maternités alors le
rapport du professeur Evil est un
rapport scientifique fait pour
l'Académie de médecine il n'engage bien
sûr en rien le gouvernement c'est un
élément de la discussion mais concernant
précisément les maternités vous savez
parfaitement que la complexité est
dossier proximité mais surtout sécurité
et des soins et il est de ma
responsabilité communiste de la santé de
la prévention d'assurer cette sécurité
partout sur le territoire
c'est extrêmement complexe au niveau de
cette équation parce que nous manquons
de professionnels les établissements les
services les maternités ne ferment pas
parce que pour des raisons financières
ça c'était avant aujourd'hui c'est pour
des problèmes simplement d'effectifs
médicaux alors l'engagement que j'ai
pris et que je continue à tenir c'est de
trouver des solutions sur chaque
territoire d'organiser des parcours de
santé pour les parturientes partout y
compris à Sedan la maternité de Sedan
qui est relayée par la maternité de
Charleville-Mézières à proximité nous
mettons en place des solutions
innovantes au niveau local que ce soit
les centres de périnatalité mais que ce
soit aussi des exemples comme depuis
quelques jours à Autun sur des centres
de périmaternité qui permettent à la
femme de rester jusqu'à l'accouchement
près de chez elle et dans les 12 heures
suivantes revenir au même endroit c'est
là-dessus que nous devons travailler
collectivement avec les élus dès
maintenant je vous remercie
madame la parole de notre collègue
Annick Jacques mes pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics monsieur Gabriel Attal elle
porte sur la compensation pour l'année
2023 de la contribution sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises la CVAE dont la
suppression progressive sur deux ans a
été acté par la dernière loi de finance
on compensation de cette perte de
ressources fiscales les collectivités
territoriales se voient affecter une
fraction de la TVA nationale de manière
pérenne et dynamique toutefois depuis
l'annonce des montants individuels de
compensation de la CVAE notifié aux
collectivités avec trois mois de retard
les élus locaux concernées ont
publiquement fait part de leur
incompréhension
en raison de la crise sanitaire
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre quelles sont
les intentions du Gouvernement pour
compenser la suppression de la CVAE sans
porter atteinte ou finances des
collectivités territoriales je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est communiste déléguée en charge des
comptes publics monsieur Gabriel Attal
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Annick Jacquemet s'il est un
point sur lequel nous nous retrouvons je
crois toutes et tous ici sur les bancs
c'est la volonté de restaurer notre
industrie et de retrouver une situation
où nous créons des emplois industriels
où nous ouvrons des usines en France on
est tous d'accord là-dessus ensuite il y
a un débat sur les modalités dit
parvenir effectivement nous considérons
qu'il faut baisser les impôts de
production comme nous l'avons fait et on
voit de premiers résultats même s'il
faut évidemment poursuivre et amplifier
notre action il y a eu ce débat et nous
avons effectivement assumé de supprimer
la CVAE et je suis absolument persuadé
même que dans le choix de la majorité
sénatoriale à l'époque de anus de
vouloir annuler la suppression de la CVE
il n'y avait pas le rejet de la baisse
des impôts de production mais des doutes
des inquiétudes sur la manière dont nous
allions la compenser pour les
collectivités locales effectivement la
première ministre a pris des engagements
très clair devant les associations
d'élus et ses engagements ont été tenus
pas un euro de CVAE pour l'année 2023
n'est gardé par l'État vous avez parlé
d'une différence d'un delta de 650
millions d'euros ils sont précisément
versés au fameux fond vert porté par
Christophe Béchu et Osis 500 millions
d'euros sur le pont vert 150 millions
sur les 10 eaux global l'écrasante
majorité des collectivités voir leur
CVAE en 2023 progressé par rapport à
2022 c'est notamment le cas chez vous
dans le Doubs j'ai regardé j'avais
regardé la proposition faite par la MF
de retraité l'année 2021 du calcul de la
moyenne mais il y aura eu 45% des EPCI
et 40% des communes qui auraient été
perdantes la réalité c'est que prendre
une moyenne sur plusieurs années ça
permet de lisser une grande volatilité
comme vous l'avez dit avec des communes
qui peuvent se retrouver sur une année
avec un trou de un trou d'air sans
évidemment avoir aucune responsabilité
je crois que le choix que nous avons
fait est protecteur pour les
collectivités les engagements de la
première ministre permettent d'assurer
que l'État ne garde rien de la CVAE
collectée et que tout est reversé au col
lectivités locales et évidemment dans le
travail qui va se poursuivre avec elle
sur la poursuite de la définition des
modalités de compensation on continuera
à avancer avec vous merci
[Musique]
nous avons terminé merci madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres avec les questions au
Gouvernement prochaine question
d'actualité le 12 avril à 15h la séance
va être suspendue elle sera reprise à
16h30 pour l'examen de la promotion de
loi visant à favoriser l'accès de tous
les étudiants innove de restauration un
tarif modéré la séance est suspendue